America's Got Talent the wild and weird
moments you didn't see on TV Plus Simon
gives us hope for a One Direction
reunion guys what other show can you get
magic death-defying stunts and humid
water fountains I'm Denny director and
last night was the first live show of
America's Got Talent
and the act of buying for that million
dollar prize turned it out some got
weird but so did I
[Music]
[Applause]
a Filipino brothers right you guys are
so much fun to watch and can we talk
about how you're still rocking the hills
[Applause]
oh my god there's a hot dog going up his
mouth want more dinner you know what no
but I will take a swig of water with you
splash zone looking shiny shimmery
splendid a lead anywhere it's a blowout
and honestly winning hair products I
gotta say you walked out here at the
Dolby theater looking like an Oscar
statuette girl well you know we are in
the double negative and we know what
happens here is the Academy Award they
you know and why does the Oscar have to
be a man honey oh that's right kind of I
blow it out every day yeah hit your toe
look at this look who else would turn
this out look good I do I feel
overdressed Simon yeah in my lessons I
do think you're an I'm gay I know I look
all smart and stuff but that's just the
dress talking what do you hope people
who watch you and your act and hear your
story take away from it I just hope that
they take away from that you can do
whatever you want don't give up on what
you want to do and come bright and
sparkly just rate ass lips wear leopard
prints as well but don't forget that
can't go wrong with leopard and glitter
no absolutely not more sequence of
better right Americans love shiny things
future Vegas act right here only afford
foil and I have been in that situation
just cover your trophy yeah creative
okay so I might have that a little too
much fun over there but can I be me what
you see is what you get folks but the
same can't be said for fourteen-year-old
powerhouse and how he's golden buzzer
singer Courtney hadwin the shy teenager
close out the show and left all of us
including the judges
speechless
[Applause]
I was like nervous when I went off the
stage and then when the music come for
an hour
I got into the music now is less nervous
but then when singing Wednesday in the
audience stand over give me that bit
more confidence right it just be over
music
she is meek and she is shy and she is
that 14 year old girl little girl but as
soon as the music hits she's possessed
and to come from I don't know but it
comes from deep inside her soul and it
is like Janis Joplin reincarnated it's a
wonderful amazing thing to watch what
was it like to be have a front-row seat
to that magic well I was saying to
someone earlier on you know like I've
done these shows a long time and there's
been moments whether it's Kelly Clarkson
Leona Lewis Carrie Underwood Chris
Vander Waal grace Camilla and always
remember that one performance where you
go that's gonna make a difference and
that was one of those moments it was
incredible so you calling it right now
she's gonna win the whole ding thing I
think so I'll say it right now she's
gonna win the whole thing
now he's calling it I'm meeting Courtney
last night told her we are not worthy of
her talent import thing was sober well
my my extra Ness and really with all the
well deserved attention but I think we
have a shining star amongst us and
someone who knows a thing or two about
turning young teens into music
superstars is of course mr. Simon Cowell
and from one direction of fifth harmony
he knows how to pick up last night I had
a dish on the future of 1d what's the
latest on One Direction will we ever get
them back together they're having a lot
of success so Louise working with me on
a show at the moment is in the UK I just
think the legacy is too big not to go
back to at one point
plus they have enough songs I didn't
realize how many hits they'd had though
they that when they do get back together
it will be a huge event but look they're
all doing their and they're all being
successful but I have a feeling it will
happen I really do please what do you
guys think Directioners time to get the
boys back together or what I'm ready all
right guys thanks for watching if you're
a fan of a GT or the daily Denny be sure
to share this video plus we have more
with Simon and what we can expect from
fifth Harmony's solo stuff and that's up
now I see you guys tomorrow